here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was if I could be any
kind of artist I'd be Jeffrey Tambor
said a painter Kathy Bates said a
sculptor Melania Trump said an escape
artist do you learn about people display
Brenes he definitely wants out if you
ask me a hurricane Harvey and hurricane
Irma are Rose Byrne said proof of global
warming Jim Parsons said why we need to
beef up FEMA Hillary Clinton said Bernie
Sanders fault people people need dogs
too
Demi Lovato said provide companionship
William H Macy said engender empathy
nicholas cage said read and choose their
scripts
[Music]
in September I like to prepare for LA's
rainy season by Mila Kunis said
double-checking my roof Zach
Galifianakis said cleaning out my
gutters real housewife Lisa Rinna's said
putting on my storm lips the coolest
thing about the movie it is busy
Phillips said there's finally a horror
movie that's genuinely scary Chris Pratt
said a new generation will now be
terrified of clowns Trump adviser
Stephen Miller said learning I'm not the
only one who likes hiding under sewer
grates dispute the joke
[Applause]
when I need a shoulder to cry on I turn
to Julie Bowen said my husband Scott
Halle Berry said my mom judith gary
busey said my washing machine Eric
watching the violence on Game of Thrones
gives me Reese Witherspoon's said
anxiety Jonah Hill said nightmares
Steve Bannon said ideas and finally I
didn't grow up celebrating Christmas
because dr. Sanjay Gupta said I was
raised Hindu Kumail Nanjiani said I was
raised Muslim Larry King said Jesus
wasn't born yet
and all is right with the world
you